welcome to this video I'm playing deck
nibsy funny funny handle I've played him
at once and one with the spanish Flag
144 feed it tells me two or three
something usf so I'm still for the
finnish flag yeah okay let's see what
what happens I'm just playing a
classical line not something crazy with
long cancelling where I don't know
what's going on let's see this is fairly
solid okay maybe I should have thought
about bishop everyone looks like the
loss of ten point I don't want to play
don't really want to play the capture
now but maybe I need him okay still
seems fairly solid just centralizing
yeah wonder how I can translate this
sense German German word of the same um
it's not so easy to translate like 11 to
one it's mostly used for for football or
soccer and for the US where those google
get us people who actually score lots of
goals often called nibsy um ok I would
like 95 but I don't really see it
happening at the moment the night on b3
is also really misplaced maybe I can and
reroute it 95 if I can always take take
be to really know ok I'm not a very very
a natural 1.e4 player and always it
becomes apparent affirmed luckiest plane
very very sharp line like like the
dragon where you really should know
something specific then I sometimes
really get into trouble that's very very
lame chest but ok I don't see didn't see
anything great at the moment ok well
before maybe I can go night at four and
then put it on d5 he might be able to
take me to which I'm beyond this kind of
considerations
yeah nida strange on there for relief
hmm interesting
yeah I don't want to give up the Bishop
of this lame Chopin Bishop g5 Bishop h4
g5
hmm
giving it up this piece like with 95 is
very ugly but Bishop g5 if he can really
maybe play this f6 g5 business and
attacked two pieces don't really see
anything against that maybe I just I can
play you sexy as well where do I go with
that actually you six was probably very
good IAM ok so that some way to to
generate an attack IAM some way like you
look at e3 h3s Bishop g7 all the time I
probably must must go back the ship be
too though could be a bit greedy right
it could be i can go here and cut off
his official from the defense maybe I
get some play now maybe Oh as you wrong
prickly plate yeah I guess so queen d 5
96 wins and queen at least what is
giving up the Queen yeah okay I mean
it's got lots of material for it there's
also Knight f3 by the way Knight f3 and
then to g5 and okay let's win the Queen
I'm not really not meeting on yourself
Oh God well okay I get to g5 I get to
define I have you can play Queen age
five and a half 90 I'm totally
overlooking everything here cool really
cool
hmm ok so he's not going to age five
okay I must go here anyway hmm now I can
at least I can take age seven maybe like
a look you for check look II for F for
something like that look you fall
time warning ya making play Quincy five
unfortunately can give the chick can
look at four check should f6 to cover it
here look I for check Bishop f6 and yeah
this is this is a drawn now check
probably have to do it it can maybe play
for win with Queen f5 check Queen a5
could be a try for a win we should we
have six I can take with the with a
perpetual I think Queen a 5m it's really
a valid try it's not playing on time
check now the beep on here so
exceptionally strong it really is maybe
g4 i am g phone and try to know i can
take i can take a five with check
possibly possibly at least I'm probably
playing g4 anyways um ok channels to
take check shaking probably I must do
this for King safety reasons anyway rook
t5 age five I couldn't have done this
immediately because I've okay one check
made a note i'm absolutely no time
try to win win time here to it to get
the beep on what you get near skin
Quincy eight is very funny it's mating
but I have no time on the clock that's
really the problem absolutely no time
check check yeah now the g point is even
promoting
check game wow what a finish I just got
the two pawns Wow whoo-hoo yeah a very
tricky game of horse i mean i was i was
totally lost ya know no question about
this this really shocked me though but
ok but it was probably just ok and I
don't really have a jacket just signs of
a check or anything to calais check yeah
funny and Bishop f6 is a dry oil can
catcher or like this I actually had
thought that this is what it's like in
my choice solid wrong unless he wants to
do status it's possible ok check i know
this end here black is yeah i thought
this actually i thought yeah black is
winning the beep on it says too much but
after this widest better should just
play b3 it seems but why it's a brutal
position generally brutal check ya hear
the computers has wide wins but here
it's a draw here Queenie south winds
yeah okay we just were we're shooting
wildly and hoping to hit something I
spotted one nice trick though this this
thing here he should play Bishop f6 and
win oops yeah I tlk I'm promoting the
Jeep on but you need some luck okay hope
you enjoyed this world game thanks for
watching